THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
IF YOU HAVE CAUGHT ANY NEWS
ABOUT THE BORDER CRISIS IN THE
LAST 24 HOURS, YOU HAVE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO A DISGUSTING AND
BLATANT ATTEMPT AT EMOTIONAL
MANIPULATION.
NOW, AT A TIME WHEN WE ACTUALLY
NEED SOMETHING CALLED REAL
REPORTING, INSTEAD WE GET THIS.
>> LOOK AT THE PHOTO.
SEE FOR YOURSELF.
THE GROUP INCLUDES MEN, WOMEN,
AND SEVERAL CHILDREN, SOME OF
THEM TRYING TO CROSS AFTER BEING
DENIED ACCESS TO THE PORT OF
ENTRY WHERE THEY COULD LEGALLY
CLAIM ASYLUM.
>> ONE PHOTO SHOWS A MOTHER
STRUGGLING TO SCOOP UP HER
CHILDREN AND FLEE THE FUMES.
>> THIS PHOTO SHARED AROUND THE
WORLD SHOWS A FAMILY RUNNING
FROM THE FUMES.
>> Laura: THAT'S IT, IT'S THE
ONE PHOTO.
SUNDAY, IN A BRAZEN ACT OF
LAWLESSNESS, SCORES OF MIGRANTS
ATTEMPTED TO RUSH THE BORDER,
AND THEY PLACED OUR AGENTS, OUR
SOVEREIGNTY, IN PERIL.
BORDER PATROL HAD TWO CHOICES.
LET THEM OVER ON THE U.S. BORDER
LIKE WHAT THEY DID TO MEXICO, OR
USE NONLETHAL TEARGAS TO REPEL
THE CROWN.
NOW, THESE ARE THE ONLY IMAGES
THE MEDIA ARE STRICT LENDING.
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WHO APPEAR TO
BE RUNNING FOR THEIR LIVES.
THE HYPERBOLE, THE METER ON THE
HYPERBOLE WAS IN FULL TILT MODE.
>> THIS IS A SHAMEFUL AMERICAN
MOMENT.
IT'S A SHAMEFUL AMERICAN MOMENT.
THOSE CHILDREN, THOSE PICTURES
OF THE PICTURES WE SAW AT THE
END OF THE VIETNAM WAR.
>> Laura: NOW, NO ONE WANTS TO
SEE CHILDREN IN DISTRESS.
BUT THAT COMMENT WAS AN
EMBARRASSMENT.
REMEMBER, DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T
CREATE THIS CRISIS.
HIS FOREMOST RESPONSIBILITY IS
SAFEGUARDING THE NATION, WHICH
IS WHAT HE'S DOING.
REPORTERS WHO ARE EITHER LAZY OR
AGENDA-DRIVEN ARE USING THEIR
OWN TOXIC AGENTS TO LURE THE
EYES OF THE PUBLIC ON THIS CRITI
EYES OF THE PUBLIC ON THIS CRITA
EYES OF THE PUBLIC ON THIS CRITL
EYES OF THE PUBLIC ON THIS CRITI
EYES OF THE PUBLIC ON THIS CRITS
EYES OF THE PUBLIC ON THIS CRITE
EYES OF THE PUBLIC ON THIS CRIT.
THIS IS WHAT REALLY HAPPENED
SUNDAY.
>> THE WAY THESE PEOPLE RUSHED
THE BORDER WAS ABSOLUTELY
MONSTROUS.
THEY PUSHED WOMEN AND CHILDREN
UP FRONT AND THEN BEHIND THOSE
WOMEN AND CHILDREN, THEY STARTED
THROWING ROCKS, CEMENT BRICKS.
THEY STARTED THROWING BOTTLES AT
OUR BORDER PATROL AGENTS.
>> Laura: JUST A BUNCH OF
MODERN-DAY PATRIOTS.
AS FOR THE MOTHERS AND CHILDREN,
DO THEY MAKE UP THE BULK OF
THOSE ARRESTED?
NO.
HERE IS OUR SAN DIEGO BORDER
CHIEF RODNEY SCOTT.
>> MAKING ABOUT 42 ARRESTS, ONLY
EIGHT OF THOSE WERE FEMALES AND
THERE WERE ONLY A FEW CHILDREN
INVOLVED.
THE VAST MAJORITY WE WERE
DEALING WITH FOUR ADULT MALES.
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE SAW THE FIRST
WAVE OF THE CARAVAN ABOUT A WEEK
OR SO AGO.
>> Laura: IN TOTAL, 69 ARRESTS
HAVE BEEN MADE IN THE CRISIS
CONTINUES TO ESCALATE, WHICH THE
ANGLE REPEATEDLY WARNED YOU
WOULD HAPPEN.
A NEW MIGRANT CARAVAN FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA, THE SECOND IN
SIX MONTHS, IS NOW HEADED UP
THROUGH MEXICO TO THE
UNITED STATES THIS WEEK.
CRUSADING REPORTERS ARE FEEDING
THE NARRATIVE THAT ANYONE
OPPOSED TO WELCOMING THESE
CARAVAN EARTH INTO OUR COUNTRY A
CARAVAN EARTH INTO OUR COUNTRY E
CRUEL, HORRIBLE, AWFUL,
ROTTEN PEOPLE.
THESE CARAVANS, IT'S GOT TO STO
STOP.
IT'S UNTENABLE.
IT'S UNSUSTAINABLE.
THE PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY WANT
ORDERLY IMMIGRATION.
OF COURSE THE ATOM SPLITTERS AT
THE OTHER NETWORK CLAIMED IT WAS
NO BIG DEAL.
>> THERE IS NO INVASION.
THERE IS NO EMERGENCY.
>> THEY ARE PANICKED ABOUT THIS
FAKE INVASION.
>> FOR EVERYBODY OUT THERE
THAT'S TELLING ME KNOW, IT'S A
REAL STORY.
WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE CARAVAN
TO COME IN.
I GO BACK TO WHAT I SAID ABOUT
MARTIANS COMING TO MY BACKYARD.
THEY ARE NOT COMING IN THE
CARAVAN IS NOT COMING.
THE LEPROSY IS NOT COMING.
>> Laura: IT'S NOT JUST THE
MEDIA KNOW NOTHINGS WHO NEED TO
BE EXPOSED.
WE ARE MAKING A LIST AND WE ARE
CHECKING IT TWICE.
OTHERS HAVE BEEN VERY NAUGHTY AS
WELL ON THIS ISSUE.
ONE OF THE PRIME DRIVERS OF THE
NEVER ENDING CARAVANS ARE GROUPS
THAT HAVE BEEN ORGANIZING THIS
CARAVAN AND OTHER CARAVANS FOR
MONTHS, IN FACT YEARS.
THEY EVEN PUT OUT A PRESS
RELEASE LAST MARCH.
IT READS LIKE SOME TYPE OF
PRIMER FOR A BORDERLESS WORLD.
THIS IS MY FAVORITE LINE.
"WE DEMAND OF MEXICO AND THE
UNITED STATES THAT THEY OPEN THE
BORDERS TO THE U.S. BECAUSE WE
ARE AS MUCH CITIZENS AS THE
PEOPLE OF THE COUNTRIES WHERE WE
ARE AND/OR TRAVEL."
WHAT?
OKAY, THEY ARE NOT AMERICAN
CITIZENS BUT THIS IS A CLASSIC
CITIZENS OF THE WORLD CLAPTRAP
THAT'S BEEN FUNDED BY
BILLIONAIRES WHO WANT TRANS
MIGRATION TO BE UNIVERSAL RIGHT.
NOW, NUMBER TWO ON OUR NAUGHTY
LIST, ACTIVIST JUDGES.
ACTING LIKE A SUPER LEGISLATURE,
DISTRICT COURT JUDGES CONTINUE
TO FRUSTRATE THE PRESIDENT AT
EVERY INITIATIVE WHEN IT COMES
TO IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
LAST WEEK, THE PRESIDENT WAS HIT
WITH TWO DEVASTATING RULINGS.
IN THE FIRST CASE, I   , ON OBAA
POINTY BAR AT THE PRESIDENT FROM
LIMITING ASYLUM CLAIMS TO THOSE
WHO ENTER THE COUNTRY LEGALLY.
IN MICHIGAN, A JUDGE ORDERED THE
RELEASE OF NEARLY 100 IRAQIS WHO
WERE INCARCERATED UNDER THE
TRUMP TRAVEL BAN.
NOW, ALL OF THIS EXPLAINS WHY
THE PRESIDENT IS RUNNING VERY
SHORT ON PATIENTS.
>> IT'S A SHAME.
IT'S A SHAME.
IT'S A DISGRACE FRANKLY.
SOME JUDGE SITTING AT SOME
LOCATION VERY FAR AWAY IS
TELLING OUR INCREDIBLE MILITARY
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT WHAT TO DO,
AND IT'S NOT RIGHT AND THAT'S
BEEN GOING ON LIKE THAT FOR A
LONG TIME.
>> Laura: THE NATIONWIDE
INJUNCTIONS HAVE GOT TO BE
STOPPED.
HE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
CERTAIN JUDGES HAVE COMPLETELY
ABANDONED THEIR ARTICLE THREE
LIMITS AND ARE TOTALLY OUT OF
CONTROL.
BUT CONGRESS, PERHAPS MORE THAN
ALL OF THE OTHER CULPRITS ON
THIS NAUGHTY LIST, DESERVES THE
MOST OF THE BLAME.
BOTH PARTIES COULD HAVE SOLVED
THIS NIGHTMARE HAD THEY ACTED TO
SHORE UP THE ASYLUM LOOPHOLES
WHILE OBAMA WAS STILL PRESIDENT.
DEMOCRATS SHOULD HAVE STRUCK A
DEAL ALSO WITH TRUMP WHILE THE
IRON WAS HOT LAST JANUARY.
REPUBLICANS WERE WILLING TO
GRANT A PATH CITIZENSHIP FOR
NEARLY 2 MILLION ILLEGALS,
FIXING THE DACA PROBLEM.
CHAIN MIGRATION, VISA LOTTERY
AND OF COURSE THE FUNDING FOR
THE BORDER WALL.
TRUMP WAS ACTUALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THE PROSPECT OF THIS DEAL.
>> I WILL CONSIDER THAT A GREAT
ACHIEVEMENT TO SOLVE THE DACA
PROBLEM.
IT'S BEEN OUT THERE A LONG TIME.
THESE ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO STAY IN
THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: IT DIDN'T MATTER.
SCHUMER REJECTED THIS OUT OF
HAND.
IT WAS MORE IMPORTANT IN THE END
FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO DENY TRUMP
A WIN ON IMMIGRATION THAT IT WAS
FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO AGREE TO
PROTECT OUR COUNTRY.
EVEN AVOID THE TYPE OF CRISIS WE
SEE ON THE BORDER NOW.
AT THE SAME TIME, MANY WEAK
KNEED REPUBLICANS, MANY OF WHOM
ARE CAPTIVE TO AGRIBUSINESS OR
THE HOSPITALITY OR CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRIES, WERE UNWILLING TO GO
TO THE MAT FOR THE TRUMP AGENDA.
SO NOTHING ENDED UP GETTING
DONE.
WITH 12 LEGISLATIVE DAYS LEFT
UNTIL THEY LOSE POWER IN THE
HOUSE AND ONLY 15 IN THE SENATE,
REPUBLICANS MUST UNITE AND MAKE
PASSING TRUMP'S IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT AGENDA A PRIORITY.
WORKING THROUGH CHRISTMAS AND
SHUTTING DOWN THE GOVERNMENT,
YES, IF THAT'S NECESSARY.
THIS IS A CRISIS THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY.
WE KNOW THAT ONCE NANCY HAS THE
GAVEL BACK, THE DEMOCRATS ANSWER
TO THINGS LIKE THIS.
IT WILL BE TO ALLOW THE
SITUATION TO WORSEN.
ENCOURAGING THOUSANDS MORE TO
STORM OUR BORDERS AND PUT WOMEN
AND CHILDREN AT RISK.
THE REPUBLICANS MEANWHILE HAVE A
CHANCE TO MAKE THIS SHORT
SESSION OF CONGRESS A LOT LESS
LAME BY ADDRESSING THE MOST
IMMEDIATE PROBLEM FACING OUR
COUNTRY TODAY.